Stephanie is in Cleveland Ohio how are
you Stephanie hi I'm doing well thank
you so much for taking my call business
merry Christmas to you how can I help
so my husband and I are ready to start
the baby steps and we sat down this past
weekend and went over our budget and we
gross about 90 K I do some babysitting
on the side and I just don't know where
we're going wrong because we are coming
up at a zero without throwing any extra
money at our debt and I don't know if
it's our car we need to so how much how
much is your car payment 370 okay how
much is your house payment
just under 1200 okay and how much is
you're still putting money in your 401 k
JH I think I'm doing like 3% or
something right now cancel that yeah
stop that temporarily and what are you
getting in tax refunds you started a new
job last year so we got a couple a few
thousand dollars on this for 2017 so I
know we're trying to make it so we're
not you know paying out in taxes right
now I'll pay out in taxes but we also
don't want $3,000 coming in a tax refund
because that's $250 a month too much
being taken out of your check okay
that's all it is a refund is I just took
too much out and then you get it back
with no interest mm-hmm so what you need
to do is when you do your 2018 taxes
early in 19 with your tax professional
you sit down and go what should really
be withheld and have that proper amount
withheld you don't want to end up having
to pay more in but you also don't need a
big refund so if you got $100 one way or
the other you hit it perfect
okay that's where you want to land with
that also are you paying a bunch of
gimmick stuff at work either one of you
before you get home with the money like
cancer insurance or short-term
disability or any of that I I pay into
short term disability yeah okay and
child
I think child's life okay all right yeah
you need to look at a lot of that you're
probably getting nickel and dime to
death on that stuff and because what I'm
trying to do is set your take-home pay
up to be you know really - only the
proper amount of taxes and everything
else comes home yes and Isis nothing
like 65 I think a little over 65 which I
mean I don't know that seems crazy to me
but you know that seems a little low it
sounds like you've got it sounds like
you've got you know too much coming out
for taxes you've got some gimmick stuff
and you're still taking money out for
the 401 K and we adjust all of that it
could be as much as you know five
hundred a thousand dollars a month okay
and that all the sudden then starts to
get this rolling so what is the balance
on the car the pay off the balance is
24,000 we were upside down on a car that
we traded in so we owe $25,000 and
selling it privately the max was 17,000
gotcha okay and pretty much other data
you have not counting your home my
husband has about seventeen thousand and
student loans we have about a little
under two thousand in credit cards
[Music]
well paying some local taxes that we owe
a couple thousand dollars to I think
it's a little under two thousand there
also and that's it okay and what unusual
expenses are you seeing in your budget
when you lay it out something that you
think other people might not see well my
son just started
piano so I didn't know that was
something we should cut out which would
be really hard to do but that's like one
hundred and twenty seven dollars a month
I was just sitting there staring at it
today trying to figure out we're paying
some of our adult children like car
insurance and why cell phone bills so
yeah yeah I guess that's something else
we need to change yeah yeah okay number
one they're adult children which I've
always thought was an oxymoron but
they're adults they ought to be paying
their own bills and it's time how old
are they ones in college she's 20 and
the other one just moved out on his own
she's 18 but he's not in school so I
kind of feel like he should be paying
both things we did start having her the
college didn't pay her car insurance
mm-hmm but we still pay for her cell
phone so well I think the thing to do is
just what we're doing here we're just
taking a comb and combing through the
tangles do you feel it yeah absolutely
so by the time you do all of that you're
going to find five hundred thousand
pretty quick and you're probably going
to end up finding more and so basically
you've got $50,000 in debt if you can
find a couple thousand dollars a month
including the payments you're already
paying not counting your house payment
your car payment then you would be
debt-free in two years that's what we're
saying and I think you can find that
over time here you just keep beating on
this keep combing the tangles out